have you heard this song gang gang gang
no the one where he's like my friend
Kevin was a pedophile like did you hear
about Marcus or Marcus yeah our Marcus a
bunch of girls say raped him in the back
of some Target did you hear the
unreleased verse he did it was leaked
let's hear it
home for the holidays my friend pulled
me to the side said did you hear about
Liam which Liam or Liam he spent A Night
at the Museum and all the mummies came
alive and he had to raise and feed him
wait which leads are Liam the one who
ate the family of worms and ate his
workers and pissing germs you're scaring
me stop could talk to fish
and he only owns one dish
that was
the best one
it's awesome